il a des allures de vaisseau spatial et
fait la fierté de ses créateurs signaux
a été entièrement programmée par ses
élèves de ce2 de l'école le berceau avec
les hardy au programme
le robot et après on appuie sur le
bouton du milieu et
d'après le programme commence un langage
qui n'a presque plus de secrets pour eux
une trentaine de classes de saint
quentin en yvelines a participé au 2e
challenge sky robe
depuis septembre ils ont travaillé avec
leurs professeurs pour arriver à ce
résultat et apprennent à prendre goût à
connaître le vocabulaire associer le
robot et puis aussi le vocabulaire
utilisé par le robot pour avancer et
obéir sur l'allemande aux ordres qui
vont leur donner
donc ça apprend dans toute chose en
termes pédagogiques mais ça apprend sur
l'esprit des clients parce qu'ils sont
pas tout seul à le faire j'ai la
mécanique
c'est ce qui fait fonctionner un
haut-parleur mouvement c5 une façon sûre
le robot c'est leur mouvement après
délibération du jury dark team your
repart avec le prix coup de coeur mais
chaque équipe a été récompensé pour son
investissement
cette année plus de 600 élèves sont
devenus apprentis ingénieurs